Hello, good morning everybody.
Sorry, we loot because I wanted to put on the pilot hat.
Sorry, the only reason why we loot was I was like, oh my
god, I should put on a hat.
And I was trying to find a hat.
I was trying to find for the immersion.
I was trying to find a hat.
looped today it's important the hat was so important you
guys don't understand how can i be a real pilot if i don't
have the hat also oh my god lemo thank you for the 50 gifted
chips thank you thank you guys i'm so incredibly tired i'm
so i i i i was like i could do 11 30 it's Just like 12.30,
but like an hour earlier.
And then I woke up at 11.15 and I was like realizing it's
not like 12.30.
I woke up like, oh, it's not like 12.30.
It's why it's so much worse.
um so so good morning everybody good morning the reason why
the reason why my stream is an hour earlier is uh because um
i'd have a meeting with youtube uh i was originally had a
meeting with youtube to just like be like welcoming me on
youtube or like welcoming me back on youtube
to meet with like the youtube people like maybe like a month
ago but then because of uh daylight savings the meeting got
like scuffed like like it got really scuffed so we had to
postpone it because like we weren't able to attend the
meeting because of daylight savings a month ago and now like
our schedule is lined up our schedule is finally lined up
today so i was like it was debate i was like do i do them do
i do this street i didn't miss it i didn't miss it our
meetings got like super scuffed up okay i'm just gonna say
it was daylight savings time but i didn't miss it we just
had to reschedule it so uh we had to reschedule it to and uh
today's the day i get to meet mr youtube himself oh my god a
real person i think like one of the funniest like first uh
the the first email we got from YouTube was like hello I'm a
real person I remember like I remember like when manager
sent me like the email it was like oh hey YouTube wants to
meet you and then like I think like the first or second
sentence was like hi I'm a real person but I really I like
the the our youtube guy he's really nice um because like i
had issues i don't know if i told you guys but like the
second channel thing was solved like uh my twitch my twitch
vlogs channel there was an issue with my twitch vlogs
channel um did i would i tell this in the members i told
this in the members right okay did i tell this in the
members or members yes i told this in the member it's
because i i leaked something in the members um so So for
those who are not in the members, in the member stream, what
happened was that my Twitch VODs channel, look, everything
like blurs together, like my entire life has been like
stream, like I feel like, like a lot, I feel like majority
of my brain space has just been like filled up with
streaming stuff that I don't know what is what anymore.
I don't know.
I was like, did I say this in the members?
Did I say this in my past channel?
Did I say this in my current channel?
said and I say this is my past channels members I can't
remember there's too many things to take into account now
it's getting more complicated it's getting so much more
complicated now so so anyway basically what happened for
those who are like super confused and are like oh what
happened basically my twitch VODs channel effort what I it
was like it succeeded in like ads yet i still need like i
think like 30 more out watch time 30 more hours of watch
time hint hint uh to get to be able to monetize via ads but
i could turn on super chats and members in my second twitch
sorry my second youtube channel which i won't do because i
think that's a little stupid because it's the vod's channel
um but i wanted to like make sure my uh make sure it's
already approved for monetization already so like just to be
like just to do it in advance and um And then, so I applied
for modernization on my Twitch VODs, my, my VODs channel.
And then I, and then I got rejected.
And I was like, what?
I was like, what?
Why did I get rejected?
It's, it's a VODs channel.
So I looked at the requirements.
And then the requirements was like, and they're like, why
did they reject me?
And then apparently one of them was that they didn't.
didn't know if it was me or it was like an impersonation or
something like they thought like oh somebody was in might
might be impersonating me and they're like oh if you're
gonna re-upload somebody else's content you gotta make sure
it has like different things on there like you gotta make it
your own you gotta edit in a way that's your own and i was
like what the fuck so so they're like okay if you want to
send an appeal prove that this is you and so i was like okay
i'm gonna i guess because i monetize VODs channel due to
like my experiences my previous experiences I know you can
monetize like VODs channel so that's like okay um I'm I
basically what I leaked was the video I sent the has to be
transformed it it was like the video I sent um uh I sent in
the members so like I let the members hear what I said and
then and so like I made a video I have to make it unlisted
and being like hi um this is me this is my channel here's my
main channel and here's my twitch channel so like you could
tell this is me and then like i sent that in i was like
here's all the like i is me i'm dokey bird this is all me
and then i sent it in and then they rejected it and was like
we don't we're like we don't know if it's you and i was like
what do you mean you don't know if it's me like I literally
said it's me what do you mean it's not me and so like they
rejected the appeal and then I had to email my YouTube guy I
was like what the fuck is going I was like I was like why
did they reject me it's me and my YouTube guy like got like
was like don't worry I got this I'll make I'll talk to them
myself I got you and so like and a day after I remember I
think like a they remonetized it they're like you're good to
go you're in the program now they're like you're good to go
you're in the program now for your second channel and it's
like yay that's all you have to do you gotta get a youtube
guy email them be like what the fuck and then they'll be
like don't worry yay oh my god so second channel monetized
anyway i have a meaning that's the reason Uh, the stream is
starting earlier.
I like how, like, I already, like, talk for 14 minutes now,
but I still have more stuff to talk about.
Uh, so I'm so sorry for the EU goons who are like, Doki,
please, we have so limited time together.
This is the one of, this is the only stream we could watch
this week at a reasonable time.
Doki, please play the game.
I'm sorry, but, like, I'm going to keep talking.
don't keep my connecting flight please start the plane
anyway uh so that is why i have a uh i have a meeting at 2 p
.m and i debate between like either streaming at three or
streaming an hour earlier because you know if i stream at my
usual time i can only do like you know not that much and i
was just like i don't want to rush it i was like i don't i
don't want to rush it i because it would be like a less than
two hour stream and i was like we don't really have a stream
for the eu guns this week so i was like oh my gosh all the
other slots were sort of taken so i was like okay like i say
all the other time slots were like all the other slots were
taking when i'm like an indie now so i control my own
schedule i don't have to reschedule something because of
something here or like overlapping or anything because
there's literally no overlaps for me But, like, anyway, as I
was saying, there was no more time slots for me to put it
in.
So, I was like, I might as well put this at 11, uh, put this
one at 11.30.
Anyway.
Anyway, um, I got some, like, oh my gosh, I'm, like, super
happy today because I actually woke up to some really good
news today.
I can't say what, but, like, I can say, like, a lot of my
dreams are coming true, and I'm just, just really happy i'm
just i'm just so happy i mean i'm just happier
but it's super exciting it's super duper exciting i'm like
really excited about the oncoming news anyway flight
simulator i've always wanted to try this game out i feel
like i'm gonna yell that a lot though uh i feel like i'm
gonna get yelled at so much because it's so, I was like
looking at the settings and I was like, what the fuck, I was
like, because it's like super immersive.
And like, I'm just like, oh man, oh no, this game might be
too easy because of how, because of how immersive it is and
how obviously amazing I am at flying.
I was like, oh man, this game could just be too fucking
easy.
Oh no.
Oh my god.
Anyway, I don't know.
I feel I'm a bit scared.
For those who are wondering, I'm still not using my, uh, I'm
still not using my new PC because it's a lot to set up for.
And, um, the new PC, there's a lot of stuff I need to do to
set up for it.
And I really, I haven't had the time to actually like sit
down and sit down and like, you know, transfer everything
over.
I feel like I think I will, like do that at another time
maybe like when i have maybe like more rest days at the
moment so i guess we're gonna stress test my my current pc
which we don't really need a stress test because we can like
you know we can we can sort of understand how how stressed
the pc already is so i feel like i have to change these
settings i don't know These settings seem, I don't know.
I'm worried here.
I'm so worried.
All right.
Do we really, I don't know, man.
Okay, we're going to try the settings out.
We're going to do a Difa.
What's the worst that could happen?
Difa.
Dave, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
If you could do a forklift, then a plane will be easy.
Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Also, I saw that you guys, good eye.
I don't know if you guys know this, but it's one of my four
birthdays.
Or is it five birthdays?
I already lost track of my own lore.
A lima thinking with a zipper check thinking, thank you.
Yes, it's one of my four of the five birthdays.
Very good eye.
Thank you.
It's my birthday, guys.
Real.
All right.
How do you play this?
What do we do?
Do we do flight training?
I guess we should do flight training, right?
Or do we go straight into it?
I feel like...
I already have enough like training guys, right?
Right?
What mode should we do?
World map?
Do we do world?
I feel like world map's gonna fucking kill my my PC.
I
Okay, but what if we do like a discovery play and what if we
go to New York City?
Okay, we shouldn't go to New York City.
I just realized the implications.
What did we do, like, I don't know, the island here, the
Bora Bora?
Alright, we'll do Bora Bora and then I don't know.
The Skyhawk, bro, what the fuck is a Skyhawk?
Okay, I want to do a real plane.
Is that real plane?
That's an real plane.
Alright, here we go.
The real plane time.
Why the fuck is it showing me a controller?
M and K.
HS.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Happy one to four to five birthdays.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Mike, thank you.
Super chat.
Thank you.
Happy birthday.
All right.
Here we go.
This is it.
I'm going to teach you guys how to be a real pilot.
Also, is Sound Guy even here?
What is the plane is this?
Does it tell me what plane it is?
The Air 3501.
Wait, that's not... I want to be in the cockpit.
Oh.
Guys.
Am I flying?
Oh my god.
Look, I'm already doing it already.
I think I'm...
My altitude is slowly going down.
How do I...
How do I pull up?
I thought I would be given more instructions.
Why am I looking it down here?
Okay, guys, we're gonna watch the slowest fucking crash.
Oh!
Why is it turning?
How do I...
Oh, this is worse!
This is worse!
Okay, I'm...
Alright, we're not going...
We're not doing that anymore.
That's why I don't, oh my god, I don't know how to change my
face.
I accidentally pressed it.
I don't know how to rechange my face.
I don't remember my face.
My, I don't remember how to use my face, guys.
I don't remember how to use my face.
Give me a sec, everybody.
Give me a sec.
All right, turning that off.
Turning my face off real quick, guys.
Gotta turn that off.
All right, there we go.
All right, okay, I realized, guys, I realized we're gonna
need to do the tutorial.
We really need to do basic handling.
All right, don't worry.
Don't worry, your pilots got this introduction.
We're going to go through a basic course through this.
It can't be that difficult.
All right.
We can't be that difficult.
Here we go.
This is it.
Maybe just a little bit of tutorial would be helpful.
I don't know why.
But like maybe just a little bit of a tutorial.
Bacon.
Thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you.
10 out of 10.
Fastest play I ever had.
Was a little concerned when a pilot asked how to fly, but
they landed on a really nice coffee fountain So it's all
good.
Yeah, see that guy gets it.
There was no fire There was no fire so everything was okay
Hello, hello Jess Why are we starting on the ground?
It's a plane.
It should be in the sky Okay
All right, I mean it looks pretty nice the ASX XGS Look at
that.
Oh my god, that's me!
There's another person in my plane!
It's my twin!
They trust me so much they put another- Look, I'm not a bad
pilot.
Because why- if I was a bad pilot, why would they put
another person in my plane?
Okay, open the basic controller's pad- there's-
Oh- I
got controller!
Give me a second let me grab my controller because
apparently this is on like I'm on what?
Okay guys all right I'm plugging in my controller because
apparently I have to use a controller I was like what do you
mean I can't even change the layout all right we have to
okay and applied okay yes keep default all right we're good
to go this can't be that bad now hey what the fuck is a
rudder toggle increase throttle oh breaks we need to know
that increase flaps oh my god guys i think being a pilot is
very i don't know guys i think it's trying to tell me that
being a pilot might be a little difficult when you're on the
plane and you hear your pod says guys how do i fly over the
intercom yes thank you for the super chat thank you thank
you all right how do i get out of here okay i got it i open
the camera open the camera panel oh my god i'm dual wielding
camera i want to be oh it says track ip i was like what okay
i want to be in the cockpit Can I change what my pilot looks
like?
Was it pilot?
Landing co-pilot?
No, I want to be my pilot.
Okay now.
Now I'm super immersive
Yeah I can turn on the cabin light
How do I point the yoke and hide it?
What the fuck is a yoke?
Oh, is this a yoke?
Oh?
Okay, wait I can turn on oh my god I can turn on strobe
lights Oh my god there's so many things How do I How do I
turn this off Okay Okay Okay Okay that's cool Oh that's why
we have a co-pilot so like If I fuck up they can like Take
the wheel Okay I'm trying to Guys I'm trying I'm trying so
all right guys okay taxi lights okay okay um um the cursor
point the where the what
okay guys where's
guys where's the yoke Okay, but like, oh my god, I can turn
on these lights, though.
There it is.
Boop, boop, boop, boop.
I can have all the lights on.
I am pressing A.
I'm pressing A.
Are we leaving?
Sir, please be patient.
Oh, yoke!
It's this button!
It's right here.
Wait, what?
Wait, I saw the yoke.
Where was the yoke?
I...
I saw it again!
There it is!
Oh my god, that's the yoke!
That is the yoke!
In these cases, you need to lock the cursor onto them in
order to interact.
Oh my god.
Take a look at the clock in the middle of the dash...
Oh my god, it's...
Go ahead and lock the cursor on it.
Wait, but...
Okay, lock the cursor.
Lock the knob by pressing A.
Okay?
That lock it?
Did I lock it?
I'm...
Am I locking?
Instructor?
Am I...
Instructor, please.
I'm pressing...
I'm trying.
Where?
Wait, I should, like, hide this one, too.
Instructor, it's not letting me lock!
Teacher!
It's not...
I'm trying Oh, it's like right here You have to click
exactly this tiny ass thing Okay, that seems like the right
time It's easy to rotate the camera You can also go in
freely in the cockpit To get a better view Oh, I need to
know my time That's the pilot You don't need to know what
time it is If they're late, they're late We can, they'll
never blame the pilot for being late They'll blame the
airlines.
Alright, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
My fightless blur.
Thank you, the super chat.
Okay, hold LB and move the camera around.
I'm holding.
Okay.
Oh, that was not LB.
Sorry.
Alright, I'm using...
Oh.
Once you find a camera position you like...
Whoa!
Oh!
Okay.
Okay, I think I like...
Alright, save.
a custom view there you go all right we're so we're so we're
so locked in guys we're really locked in now okay i want to
go make sure we're we're hot we're lower all right all right
so i could just see the controls i like that yeah this one i
like this height press lb and save using yeah this is not
saved save save Save?
Save?
Okay,
I don't think...
Okay, I don't think they let me have that as a custom.
Okay, save.
Save?
Save.
Oh, there we go.
Then try switching to your custom one again.
Alright.
Okay, nice.
And then LBY?
Oh, okay.
I want this to be my custom though.
Try to familiarize yourself with them.
a bit more there you go this is the perfect original
position whenever you're done okay reset all right done I
did it that's it that was okay guys guys I got an A I'm
ready to fly I think I'm ready to fly honestly honestly
after all that yes I think I'm ready.
I said, I'm ready.
I figured it out, guys.
I fucking figured it out.
Alright.
We're gonna... Let's go to...
Alright, let's see.
Let's go to...
Seattle.
I wanna go see the... I wanna see the fucking space needle.
Alright, fly.
And then... Oh, wait.
Arrival.
And then we depart from... I don't know where this is.
What state is that?
I don't know.
There we go.
We're so ready.
We're so fucking ready now.
I got an A.
My instructor said I got an A.
Chat.
How badly can I fuck up now?
I can't fuck up if the instructor gave me an A.
Alright.
Oh, thank god.
It's just me.
Guys, it's okay.
Release the parking brake.
Apply throw throttle.
Okay, watch this, guys.
Okay, we're gonna...
I like to have...
I'm gonna turn off the visibility here.
And then we're gonna turn on all the lights.
Boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop.
Okay.
And then we gotta have...
We gotta have the cabin light on and everything.
And then...
What the fuck is an alternator?
That's a gun.
And then we're gonna do...
I think we're good.
I think we're good to go.
All right.
Throw a full throttle time.
Am I...
How do I go forward?
That should be full throttle.
Oh!
I'm going forward!
All right.
Looks good.
I think we're good.
And then we go up.
Okay.
Am I going straight?
seems all right I'll eventually fly up because of the
velocity right raise it higher and lift up oh I'm flying oh
my god oh
guys did you see that I was in the air
Guys, did you see that?
I flew!
Oh my...
Oh my god!
I'm a natural.
I do, I could do it.
Okay, guys, I think I need another lesson.
I need another lesson.
Okay, I think...
Alright, guys, I think I need another lesson here.
I learned about yoke and reading basic...
I don't need to read basic instructions.
Maybe I do.
All right, here you go.
Oh, well, way to die.
You're not dead.
Nothing exploded.
It was just a minor inconvenience.
And so it's just minor inconvenience, chat.
Nobody, everybody's okay.
So dramatic.
Okay, we're learning.
Slowly but surely.
It should give me like a bigger aircraft.
I don't want to drive this tiny-ass plane.
Alright.
Thank you, instructor.
Yeah.
Ooh.
I'm getting on board for these flights.
Breezy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I flew!
I flew at the trailing edge of the wings while turning the
yoke to see the effect on the ailerons.
Oh my god, do you see that?
The ailerons?
Okay.
Do you see that?
It's moving up and down.
Down!
I'm doing that.
This guy trusts me.
Look at him.
Like my bodyguards.
The what?
The elevator?
Is that what an elevator?
Truly a former Air Command Air Force Hero.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, Pink.
yeah oh my god wait i have breaks they control the rudder at
the end of the oh whoa that's new for coordinating turns or
compensating for a plane's tendency to pull left during
takeoffs and climbs wait sorry what did she say about the
reason for breaks to see the effect on the rudder look at
the vertical tail and then move by using and by using well
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Move by RT.
Oh, look at that.
It's flapping.
Oh, my God.
It's saying hi.
Oh.
That's how you turn, right?
Look at the throttle.
Is that the throttle?
This is where I drive.
Keep it selected and push it forward to increase power.
increase power guys I think I realized why I crashed guys I
think I realized also thank you flight attendant for telling
me to for telling me to to increase the sound and not push
enough much more do you want me to push it there you go
Okay.
Oh my god, there's so many things to know.
Where the fuck is my co-pilot?
Deselect the throttle.
And increase power.
Look away.
Why do I...
Oh, I can just hold.
Oh!
I can just hold it.
Hold B to decrease.
Oh!
I'm doing it.
You'll be able to see the power change on your rpm indicator
what the fuck is oh that's my co-pilot spot who's gonna tell
me about my rpm meter that's so far away from me look at
your current speed on the air speed indicator where's that
it's on the left oh okay thank you thank you instructor
As long as I go fast, that's all that matters, right?
Okay.
All right, Dragoons, you're my co-pilot.
Guys, you want to make sure we don't crash because if we
crash, we both die.
You'd be like, oh, it's so funny.
Don't keep crash.
You're in the same plane.
We both crash.
Like, it's your fault as well.
That's all for today.
That's it?
Next time, we'll see how it feels in the air.
What?
That's it?
You just... What?
Guys!
Oh my god.
I think I'm ready for real this time.
Guys.
I think we're ready for real.
Okay.
Let's like go in the air first.
I'm going to at least...
We're going to try to go in the air.
And then after being in the air.
We're definitely ready.
Okay.
I'm thinking of the super chat.
Thank you.
you i will go out in the blaze for the content thank you for
the super chat thank you thank you okay i'm in the air you
chose a great day to go flying i did this session we'll get
started with some basic controls sound good oh my god i'm in
the air first things first let's get familiar with your
surroundings okay out your side windows my god it's
beautiful we have great Super chat, thank you, thank you.
As someone who works in aviation maintenance, thank you for
keeping me employed.
Thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Oh, it is, look at that, it's so beautiful.
I love how unrendered this is.
There's an airport?
Where?
Is that an airport?
What the fuck is that?
That's an airport?
Oh, the instructor flies?
What if I don't want you to fly it?
Where was my turn?
That's not fair.
I'm the pilot.
I'm wearing the hat.
That's not fair.
It's like she doesn't trust me.
It's like my fucking co-pilot doesn't trust me.
They don't even let me fly the thing.
I'm going to turn on the fucking lights.
Oh, I can't.
They just say...
They won't even let me turn on the lights.
Why did they disable everything?
Okay.
The aircraft is currently set to a cruise attitude.
The position it should be in for regular flight.
I wouldn't either.
Now let's try banking into a turn by moving the yoke.
Oh.
Okay.
Monkey see, monkey do.
Wait, but her thing's not moving.
Oh my god.
Autopilot is on, isn't it?
You can't fool me.
The yoke isn't even moving.
As a general rule, you always are 30 degrees.
I don't know if it's under 30 degrees.
Which one do I look at for that?
Which one do I look at?
I don't know if it's...
Do I have to be outside?
Okay.
I don't know if it's 30 degrees.
I have controls Oh my god I'm gonna turn on some lights Oh
Oh Oh I want to turn on the pilot heat My cushy is cold I'm
gonna turn on the pilot heat And then I'm gonna turn on I'm
gonna turn on the landing lights Because I might be landing
soon And then the taxi lights Alright We Oh Oh
We're okay.
See?
We're okay!
Look at that!
We're going to Sedona!
That's like a song, right?
They were not okay.
Let's try climbing up and down.
Up and down.
Gently pull on the yoke to climb.
Yay, that's climbing right hold your pitch up for five
seconds.
What does that mean?
Excellent.
Oh, okay
Those beeps are not those beeps are not out good All right,
gently push forward hold your pitch down for five seconds.
Okay next time be a bit more gentle on the controls i'm so
gentle do you guys not see that time to find the airport
again look around oh it's this way make it turn in that
direction
guys guys i thought it'd be funny i thought it'd be funny
guys
okay i got a little impatient yeah guys i thought my my
Pilot, I thought guys, I thought my co-pilot would stop me.
I really thought, I really, I really thought my co-pilot
would stop me.
Well, they take you with the super chat.
Thank you.
Yo!
And then look at the fucking scenery again.
I thought they would stop me.
What's the point of having a co-pilot if they don't stop
you?
From making stupid decisions.
Your co-pilot's here to stop your intrusive thoughts.
I just think my co-pilot was not doing her job.
They could have fucking... They could have fucking took
control of the yoke.
That's not my fault.
They could have literally took control.
It's their life, too.
Oh my god, I can turn...
on a crew volume okay enjoy the view all right i'm enjoying
the view guys look at that beautiful airport over there it's
not my fault mine choose the thoughts one what's the point
of having a co-pilot they don't stop you from making
terrible decisions like i might as well be like the only
person in this plane you have five or two gate co-pilots and
no one why did you guys not stop me You guys were supposed
to be my co-pilots.
Why didn't you guys stop me from letting my thoughts win?
All right, the aircraft is currently set to a cruise
attitude the position it should be in for regular flight I
still can't read all of these There's too many fucking Meter
circle things in front of me.
What's this is this the time?
Oh, so that's how you do the turn That's such a smooth turn,
man.
Why can't I fly like that?
I can and I will.
I'm going to prove y'all wrong.
JK, because I can.
As a general rule, you always want to keep your turns under
30 degrees.
Okay.
How do I know it's with 30 degrees?
I'm not good at math.
Can I have access to the plane now?
Okay.
I want to...
Alright.
Okay.
I'm going to turn on the light.
turn on the heat position and then the light here.
What's this red button?
Long time flight simmer.
Very recent dragon here.
This is fantastic.
Keep up.
See?
This person thinks I'm fucking flying the plane perfectly.
August.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I knew I was doing things right.
If this long-term flight simulator player thinks i'm doing
okay then i'm right and you're wrong fake donated don't
enable it gently pull back the yoke to increase the is that
gentle
what you mean that's so gentle for the descent is the same
principle except you're pushing on the yoke go ahead gently
pitch down okay i think i'm doing it okay there guys uh
we're experiencing some turbulence right now this is just
turbulence is this what turbulence is look around and when
you found it make it turn in that direction oh wait it's
this way we okay we gotta go up though when we're turning we
this will turbulence guys we're just experiencing turbulence
it's not it's not man-made error it's just turbulence okay
captain dokey we're losing altitude reduce speed to 138
knots and pull up on that yoke charlie thank you for the
super chat thank you thank you it's sort of it fucks the
airport fine and turn towards the airport where the fuck is
it they're just all houses what the fuck build all these
houses next to my airport where the fuck is the airport oh
my god i'm still flying i can't see the goddamn airport is
that the airport is that the runway that's the runway right
guys where the fuck is the Is it behind me?
No, that's the airport, right?
Just landing on the floor.
No, that's a road?
Oh my god.
Okay, we're gonna find this goddamn airport.
Or turn your head.
Oh, oh my god, guys.
I could turn my head.
Okay, no, that's not the airport.
Oh, there it is.
There it is.
I see the airport.
It was right behind me this entire time.
There you go.
I was like, I was like, turn police for the love of God.
Turn your head.
You're fine.
There's like a drug world we're too fired a pilot.
Look, I didn't say how I got my license.
Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
There you go.
I found it.
Guys, I found the airport.
The shipments are soft and gentle.
To go deeper into handling and techniques.
I do it?
Soon enough, you'll be able to enjoy trips all on your way.
your own oh my god i'm a certified pilot look at that a b
why would i deserve a b that was just turbulence killing
thank you for the super chat thank you thank you oh my god
how come turbulence affected my my grade that's not fair all
right altitude refers to the aircraft's nose position
relative to the horizon there's three pitch altitudes
controlled by the elevator and And in this lesson, you'll
learn to climb, cruise, and descend.
I don't need to learn how to do that.
I just go up and down.
The B for Tokeper.
B for best pilot.
Exactly.
That's why I got a B.
You're telling how good I was at flying this plane.
It was so majestic.
Okay.
To help demonstrate pitch, I've drawn three lines on the
windshield.
I don't feel comfortable with my pilot has, like, these
three lines.
lines on the plane.
Before you get on the plane, make sure your plane doesn't
have these three lines drawn on there.
Because that means it might be driven by dokeybird.
Let's dig deeper into what that means.
Pull back gently on the yoke until the climb horizon.
Then maintain that attitude.
Oh!
I see.
According to your altimeter, we're gaining altitude.
Oh, tritunery.
Wait, I need no physics?
I need no map to be a pilot?
Okay.
Our speed is increasing and our altitude is stable.
Alright.
That's why you don't migrate like other birds breeds than
you and Super Chat.
Because I like to stay inside.
That attitude line matches the horizon.
Then maintain that attitude.
the attitude okay that's altitude onto the horizon for 10
seconds okay oh my god I have to look at all these fucking
circles that's a too many circles to look at after look I
want to enjoy the scenery bring the crews out to lie The
speed is decreasing and your altitude is stable.
That's okay.
Try to make only small adjustments to your pitch to avoid
overcorrection.
Am I doing it?
I did it.
Those are small.
All right.
Would you be comfortable your pilot was like a B student?
man i mean it's for b for best right that's how the markings
are go a is all right b for best c for completionist d for
done job good all right turns oh my god i can do barrel
rolls i'm gonna learn how to do paladin David
D for Doki D for Doki
I don't know I don't know what I expected
I don't know I thought it'd be different I really thought
this would be different.
Okay, but what if I do this while pulling up?
Maybe it'll be better.
Line to help you make properly for left turns.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, I did it!
Oh my god, guys, guys, I did it!
Guys!
Did you guys see that?
Oh my god!
With the risk of your lives!
I did it!
I pulled it off!
Okay.
Watch your altitude.
It wasn't constant during the turn.
Now let's see you level back out.
That's okay.
I did it.
I'm professional already.
Remember to maintain altitude.
Is this the dokey dokeybird flight airport sounds horrific?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Why are you doing this?
What the fuck is that?
10 degrees each.
Air travel.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I've flown a real Cessna for 152.
Except it was an Ardobat.
No 152 is so easy.
to fly especially in slow flight and sleep turns see guys
this is so easy that's basically what they're saying so
thank you for the super chat thank you thank you what
they're saying is i'm doing a great job
i'm doing amazing right now that's exactly what the super
chat implies right maintaining it right now Working to
maintain a constant.
I land my plane
Oh Oh now she takes control Okay, not gonna lie.
She should have taken control like before I did my barrel I
like how now she like he takes control of the plane My
leveled but i did it see oh for completionist for uh
completionist guys see for completionist guys i did a great
job thank you instructor all right what's this power
settings the basics straight level altitude okay i feel like
i don't need a note of basic handling anymore i feel like
it's all about off and landing and then after that i should
be fine oh airliner trainer okay we're gonna go with i don't
need to know basic stuff anymore i just need to know how to
take off firing space to the runway take off and then i'll
figure out landing later uh i went to take off and then
we're gonna figure out landing on the on the go uh we're
gonna figure out landing live all we need to know is
All right, Texas, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Wait, I gotta get more immersive for that.
Okay,
guys, as your main flight.
There's an old saying I like.
A mile of road will take you a mile.
A mile of runway will take you anywhere.
Taking off isn't hard, but first, we always take off into
the wind, which won't be an issue on a common ground.
day like today second before we enter a runway we always
make sure it's clear check to the right to see if a vehicle
is i don't think there's anybody here i think they know i'm
flying a plane today yeah i think they know i'm flying today
all right yeah seems clear everything looks good no traffic
go ahead and
tap your plane just after the number 21.
all right slightly increase the power that should be good
and then we're going to go to the center of the oh oh oh
guys guys it wasn't slight guys guys it wasn't
okay I'm gonna figure this because I realized it was not
slight it was not slight chat a mile of road will take you a
mile a mile of runway will take you anywhere right there
guys guys guys guys guys guys why is it not turning guys the
trees oh okay okay there you start oh thank god i think i'm
my co-pilot oh my co-pilot to control Oh, thank God!
Check to the right to see if a vehicle is on the runway.
Okay.
Then stop your plane just after the number 21.
All right.
We're slowly.
We're so slow now.
Okay.
Like, dragons, you guys saved the plane.
You're heroes.
He saved the plane from me.
Okay.
Next time, watch the runway and the approach.
No!
Oh!
Now slowly taxi onto the runway and align the plane with the
same thing.
center line is the center is the center guys in mind this is
because i don't think i'm in the center guys that breaks
where's how do i how do i get the breaks
ah how do i how do i do the breaks okay All right, we're
going to taxi onto the runway and align the plane with the
center line.
Then stop your plane just after the number 21.
Oh, there's 21.
Guys, I think I passed 21.
I think I...
But it's okay, I'm in the center now.
I'm in the center, though.
Guys, I think 21 is, like, way behind me not gonna lie.
around maybe the co-pilot would take me back to the let me
pick up ma'am ma'am ma'am take me back take him oh oh oh go
back in position oh thank god oh okay never mind i collided
with the object
okay this time i got it there's an old saying i like okay
we'll take you anywhere oh my god this This is a break.
Oh, this is a break.
Okay.
Power am I on?
I'm on 7%.
Before we enter a runway, we always make sure it's clear.
Check to the right to see if a vehicle is on the runway.
And to the left to make sure nobody here.
Guys, I remember how they used the break.
Look.
Look, see?
Am I ready?
Guys, I remember.
Okay.
Look left.
I did it.
Thanks for flying with Tokyo Airlines.
Come on, thank you for the superchild.
Thank you.
Maybe I just do a little...
Okay.
Maybe I have like 24.
There you go.
This should be the center now.
god guys i'm reading i told you all i need to do is learn i
just need to learn i just need to learn how to take off
we're gonna learn how to land while we're on in the air okay
break oh my god oh my god we're doing it slowly come on
we're we're slowly getting there
All right, slow and steady.
Slow and steady, Toki.
Slow and steady.
You have multiple crashes now.
All right, here you go.
And then...
Is that it?
Yeah.
We're going to take off.
We're going to apply full power.
She gave me permission.
Oh my god, I'm in the center.
Oh
Where's 55 now slowly taxi onto the runway and align the
plane with the center line Then stop your plane just after
the number 21.
Oh, this is good.
Oh, oh, oh Guys, I don't guess it's okay.
We don't guys guys Okay Pull back on the yoke to take off.
There you go.
Yeah Yay!
Tokey trip.
We're doing it!
We're in the air!
Where's 75?
Where is 75?
Oh, we're 75.
Use your rudders to keep the runway heading of 210 degrees.
Maintain 75 knots and we'll reach our target altitude of 75.
Oh, oh, I'm at 75.
okay where am i 5 000 i don't know where's 5 000 oh i want
to turn on the heat though my butt is getting a little cold
yeah okay then we're gonna turn on the lights yeah and then
oh oh i need to pull up i need to pull up i need to pull up
maintain heading what's 210 degrees is this 210 oh oh it's
okay it's fine oh there we go What feet am I on?
I'm learning.
Am I getting higher?
Look!
Look at all these people down there who are very safe.
Look at them!
They're so safe right now.
I don't know.
I always, like, get scared when, like, whenever...
I never want to live.
closer to an airport well to be fair other than like the
noises and stuff but like i always get like when the play
when you hear the plane landing like hear the plane in the
sky and you're like oh nocturio thank you for the super chat
thank you thank you flying she's not even forklift certified
yeah good job whoo yay all right i think we're ready i think
we're ready guys Wait, I want to make sure I can handle,
like, an actual aircraft.
Alright, airline training.
Alright, this is it.
This is, like, we need to learn how to take off for this.
And then we're going to be ready.
Yeah.
We just have to be able to drive a plane.
Alright, here we go.
We just need to be able to drive a real plane.
A real fucking plane.
Not the baby planes.
Oh, wait, what the fuck?
What the where's the wheel?
Where the fuck what happened to the wheel?
But luckily we have some extra tools They're all these
buttons A little easier once we're airborne For starters,
the auto thrust Managed I'm gonna sit in the middle Oh, we
have autopilot We'll keep us on track with navigation
All right, we're sitting in the middle.
We're going to be both pilot and co-pilot.
I'm going to execute a straight-out takeoff.
After you complete the initial climb, I'll take the
controls.
But first, check the MCDU for our reference speeds.
MCDU?
I already typed in today's numbers.
The rotation speed.
Numbers?
It's 131 knots.
I'll call out when we reach it.
Take a look at the PFD now.
PFD?
what are these words you just need to begin a gentle
rotation by pulling back on the side stick don't exceed 10
degrees until you've lifted off next let's review the thrust
levers we need to be aware of three different detents use
the climb detent labeled CL on your throttle to
automatically manage the thrust for the remainder of the
flight toga to take off at full power on short runways or
when performing a go-around and for today This is like going
from one ear to the other.
I'm fucking, I can't register what she's telling me to do.
I don't need to save fuel, is it that?
We don't need a save fuel.
What is this?
Okay, we're ready to go.
Apply half forward side stick.
Then move both thrust levers gently forward to 50%
Is that 50%?
Move thrust levers to selected takeoff thrust by pressing A.
Is that...
Is that it?
Am I doing it?
Did I do it?
Am I gonna fly now?
Is that the ocean?
Oh, we're flying.
Guys,
guys, we're flying.
Oversed?
What does that mean?
What?
Is that me?
Go higher?
Do I go faster?
Okay, now the auto thrust is armed.
Use the rudder to keep us on the center line.
Rotate 80.
Positive climb.
I'm not on the rudder.
Oh hey, there's people.
Engage autopilot.
Oh, autopilot.
Can either be engaged five seconds or 100 feet after takeoff
to manage heading and altitude.
Mega overseas.
Look at city.
What the...
To climb detent.
To climb?
Press B.
What?
What's over speeding?
I don't know!
What is overspeeding?
Overspeed.
I'm like, what?
What does that mean?
Where's my flight attendant?
I did it.
Oh, wait.
I did not do it.
How did I fail?
It means overspeed.
at 10 000 feet or 4 000 meters once over the target roll
over and cut the throttle pull stick up to 90 angle degree
hold on to one one let's thank you for the super chat thing
guys i think i'm ready guys guys i think i'm actually ready
guys for real this time okay we're gonna grab a We're gonna
grab a real plane.
A real person plane.
Wait, do I not have the real planes?
Oh no, it's up here.
Okay.
Air... Wait.
Is that a real plane?
Oh my god, the bowen!
We're grabbing a real plane.
Okay, and then that's gonna be my plane.
I think I learned enough, guys.
Oh my god, I can be green.
I can be blue.
I can be... Oh my god, the aviators club.
all right here i'm gonna be that plane and then i'm gonna do
what i can customize flight number okay my flight number
will be oh okay i was gonna write it really fucked up
nice all right nice all right there we go that's gonna be my
flight number oh no no my flight Okay, there we go.
All right, we're gonna...
Where should we go to?
Let's see.
We should go to...
Who wants me to...
Be at their airport?
I can't move.
Okay.
Whoa!
That was a weird globe spin.
Oh my god, I should fly at night time.
All right.
The UK.
Nothing bad happens in the UK.
Glasgow.
All right, we're gonna Departure GlossGal And then we're
gonna head over to We're gonna head over Oh my, wait, what's
this?
We're gonna go to We're gonna go to You know what, let's go
to Let's go to Germany All right, arrival There you go Nice
All right, Iguu This is for you.
Oh, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
What could possibly, exactly, what could possibly go wrong?
Is that that Germany?
That's Belgium.
Sorry.
My European.
This is for you, EU guns.
As I ruined geography.
We're going to Belgium.
They know German there too.
They're like, they are like, they know German, French, and
English because they're scared.
Washed up by, like, several other countries.
Is that Belgium, or is that a different country?
No, I should be right.
Because we all know I'm great at geography.
Alright, don't worry, Eugud!
As I mess up.
Oh, my God!
Where are the lights?
Oh, oh, oh, okay.
Where can I turn on the lights?
light give me a sec the pilot there's buttons behind me what
the fuck oh my god why is there buttons behind me okay um no
i'm gonna put can i put my put my brake back on no it'll be
fine okay um oh my god there's a yoke oh my god how do i
turn on the lights
okay guys i'm trying to figure out how to turn on the lights
right now give me a sec okay that's oh instrument lighting
okay that's already a hundred okay map brightness okay
inoperative okay mdf brightness oh how do i how do i turn on
the lights above me
guys guys the captain needs some help right now I need more
lights press F for flashlights guys oh my god maybe I
shouldn't have driven at nighttime guys I realized nighttime
was the mistake oh I could get the ATC on okay all right ATC
tell me what to do flight assistant okay flight assistant
that's that's not assisting me right now that's not all
right let's see what's that is that the map oh my god that's
where we are let's put the map here this is where like all
the overlays are out for us to the checklist the basic
control travel to weather all right and then okay guys we're
gonna change the date we're gonna guys i realize let's make
it the morning now
guys we're gonna adjust everything here all right and then
let's see oh what's what is this okay we're gonna put that
here as well and then um what's this the camera what's the
camera what's the camera what is the camera she found the
light switch um that's why i was thinking
You captured this figuring out the controls.
She's going to block the entire screen.
Alright guys, don't worry.
I turned on.
I found the light switch, chat.
Chat, I found the light switch.
I turned on the sun.
I did it.
Alright.
What's the camera, chat?
What is that?
that the main light the light switch of the the light switch
of the earth all right okay okay now i can't see my plane
anymore uh oh is it do i take pictures of me driving the
plane with the camera okay um oh guys i think it was a bad
idea for having all these overlays i need to put turn off
these overlaid chat.
I think...
Guys, I think it was a bad idea.
We don't need the ATC.
Alright, I think we're ready.
Guys, I think we're ready.
Okay, give me an immerse.
Okay, wait, wait, wait.
Let me pull something up real quick.
Alright, give me a sec, guys.
Give me a sec.
Let me pull something up real quick.
are you guys ready for the immersion um ladies and gentlemen
uh welcome on board to flight 69 uh with service from where
are we glasgow to uh brussels we're currently a third in
line for takeoff and are expected to be in the air in
approximately uh we ask that you please fasten your seat
belts at this time and uh secure all baggage underneath your
seat or in your overhead compartments.
We also ask that your seats and table trays are in the
upright position for take-up.
Please turn on all personal electronic devices including
laptops and cell phones so you can be sure to have a
dokeybird on your screen watching her drive this plane.
Smoking is allowed for the duration of the flight uh because
she likes the challenge thank you for choosing at doki
airlines and enjoy your
flight sorry uh good afternoon passengers that was the
flight attendant announcement i am also your flight
attendant and your pilot just do not worry when our pilot
starts in i'm gonna start Anyway, this is your captain
speaking now.
First, I'd like to welcome everyone on, uh, on the Dokey
Airlines Flight 69.
We're currently, we're currently not cruising at any
altitude.
Uh, the time is, uh, we've like turned on the sun and the
time should be around 6.45 a.m.
Uh, the weather looks good.
When with the tailwind outside, we're expected to land in
Guadalajara.
In Guadalajara's approximately, uh, 15 hours behind
schedule.
Sit back, relax, and enjoy the rest of the flight.
All right, I think we're good.
I think we're good.
I think the passengers are okay, chat.
I think the passengers know what's up.
All right, guys, this is it.
We've trained for this.
Dragoons, we've trained for this.
Am I on?
Apply throw throttle.
That should be full.
Ooh, that's a lot of numbers going up.
Whoa.
Alright.
We're just going to keep the aircraft straight.
That was a lot of numbers that I saw going up.
But that should be good.
One Doki airline ticket.
Please see?
Sure.
Thank you for the macheta soup.
Thank you.
People believe in me.
All right.
Are we good?
It's 104.
Okay, we're pretty sure all of these are up.
Oh, I forgot.
There we go.
I had my brakes on.
Do not worry.
The pilot knows what she's doing.
All right, here you go.
Yay!
Am I in the center?
I am, right?
This has to be the center, right?
Yeah.
Agent, thank you for the magenta super.
Let me look away from...
Okay, raise aircraft nose and lift off.
Okay.
Don't worry.
We're doing it.
We're going higher.
There's no overdrive.
We're going higher now.
Alright.
That's fine.
Raise landing gear.
What the fuck is landing gear?
You love it when you hear your pilot say, what the fuck is
landing gear?
Can I...
How do I turn on autopilot?
Is the autopilot on?
Do I have to drive this myself now?
I can't believe my captain is my OSHA.
We're not gonna make it, bros, but it's been an amazing
ride.
What the fuck?
Where are you believers?
Where are my believers in chat?
Glasgow Tower Boeing Alpha Sierra.
747 frequency change.
Am I going up?
Am I doing it?
I don't need clearance.
I'm dokeybird.
Okay, we gotta go this way.
Clear through the Charlie Airspace.
I think we're okay, right?
Clear through the Charlie Airspace, Boeing 747.
I did it!
They cleared us!
Guys!
they cleared us guys the turbulence um passengers please
remain in your seats uh we're experiencing some mass
turbulence right now so do not worry this is just turbulence
it's not the pilot doing a funky drive oh my god okay we
gotta go higher i want to do a barrel roll on my there's
like there's this like famous like fucking video where we're
like uh passengers we're me sick barrel roll right now wait
let me see if i can pull it up i'm gonna find it okay guys
i'm tabbing out i think i should be fine i think my plane
will be okay okay uh let me see i can find that audio clip
pilot pilot okay uh audio oh my god it was like so long ago
okay it was like airplane um oh i don't remember where it is
no i don't remember what it's called oh no oh okay don't
worry we're fine i tapped out it's fine did you say goodbye
we're fine does anyone remember that audio clip it was from
tumblr by the way for anyone the audio clip of the the guy
that was pretending to be a pilot and he's like don't worry
passengers we're gonna perform a sick barrel roll i hear you
see i told you we're fine you can use your phone and and
see look everybody's okay where the fuck is my food flight
attendant
wait for me to oh god i just remember we never learned how
to land we never learn how guys i just realized we never
learned how to land the plane we'll be fine you're losing
altitude how do you know if i'm losing altitude i could
barely read any of these is it because i'm going down
contact
Oh, they're saying goodbye.
Is that me?
Oh, that's me!
I think
we're fine.
Like, we're like 420.
I should have selected a closer place.
It's way too long.
Okay, I'm gonna pull up.
And then I'm gonna tab out.
Okay.
We're fine.
We should be fine.
Can you tell that I'm not tapped into the game yet?
Can you tell?
We're fine!
Everybody's fine!
Stop panicking!
Guys, look!
We're okay!
Why is everybody panicking?
We didn't learn to land.
I think that's like the worst part.
I think the worst part is that we actually did not learn how
to land this plane.
So like, that's going to be...
That's going to be an issue for us later on.
We actually forgot to learn how to land the plane.
Guys, why did you guys forgot to teach me how to land the
plane.
We all had one job.
This is so far away.
I'm just gonna land here on the Stonehill farm.
Fuck this.
I'm just gonna land here.
Alright, I'm gonna land in a Stonehill farm airstrip.
This is way too far.
I chose the destination I chose was way too far.
It's gonna take us forever!
It's like 414 like something meters to that farm we go wait
how do i use autopilot i forgot how to use the autopilot
which button does that is this did i click autopilot i think
i did did i do it
no i don't want autopilot Okay.
I don't know what I pressed.
Wait, am I high enough for a barrel roll?
Okay, guys.
The moment we get closer...
What did I click?
Were we sideways?
The autopilot tried to realign me, so I'm like, oh my god,
was I unaligned this entire time?
Please go higher?
but why it doesn't matter there's no people down there there
might be people in the flame there's no people there's no
people down there they don't care
i'm flying there's still 400 away oh my god this is gonna
take forever bro
saying we all have to we all have like important
appointments okay okay thank you for the super chat thank
you thank you imagine a plier let's set the ira i'll just
land here in the middle of nowhere thank you for the super
chat thank you thank you no don't keep my flight as to
tomorrow please don't give me anxiety thank you for the
super chat thank you thank you what do you mean
look everybody's everything's fine everything's fine chat
everything make sure you have your electronic devices on
with wi-fi on too so you can watch a donkey bird stream okay
all right guys i think we're doing pretty well see am i high
enough in the sky i should be higher like i don't think it's
good that i can see the city like i don't think i just
realized it might not be a good thing that the city is like
in my view.
So maybe I should be a little higher, I feel like.
Right?
Yeah, I should not be able to see the city.
Wait, are the gears down?
Wait, what does that mean?
What do you mean, what altitude am I on?
Does it tell me what altitude I'm on?
Why is it only a two?
Okay, there it is.
I see it's at the bottom right.
You don't see it, but I see the altitude.
I'm going to keep pulling up until the altitude.
What's that sound?
That's a good job sound, right?
That should be the good job.
Okay, I'm like 16,000.
Okay, okay, here we go.
Alright, here we go.
I'm at 17,000 altitude now.
Alright, this is good.
That's good.
I should be higher, though.
I feel like I should be at like 20K, right?
Half the fuel.
It's been half the fuel this entire time.
What is, like, the optimal amount of altitude that I should
be on?
Because I'm at 17,000 right now.
30k?
Okay, we're so fucking far.
Can I be...
Can I turn on my autopilot?
Is my autopilot on?
No.
Is my autopilot?
What is my autopilot doing?
What is it doing?
Why is it going down?
Autopilot, go back up.
What is my autopilot doing?
I turned off autopilot because I couldn't tell what they're
doing.
I couldn't tell what it's doing.
It was going down!
It's flying around, but it's right there!
It's right in front of me!
Why would it change its course?
Here's to your heading and altitude.
The altitude, but we have to go up!
We need to go up!
I am doing a better job than...
I wonder what does these do.
I wonder what happens if I turn on all of these.
Ooh.
What's this?
Oh, that's the brakes.
I should not...
I should not touch that.
But, like, what are all these buttons, though?
The rudder trim?
What does this do?
That's not good, right?
The seat...
Oh, turn on your seat bounce, everybody!
turn off your seat belts wait off i'm gonna turn it off guys
turn off your seat belts oh that's how they do it oh guys
we're at 20k guys oh my god guys we're at 20k guys okay all
right and then What is this?
Okay, that's the seatbelts are off.
That's good.
That's all we wanted.
And then...
Where are these buttons?
Where are these buttons, dude?
Am I... Okay, we're okay.
We're okay.
I just have to be sure.
I have to be sure that we're okay.
Ooh, that's way too close.
I don't want to...
I don't want to look at the controls like that.
Oh my god, it's still so far!
Ooh, let me fix the controls here.
There we go.
All right.
Wait, where the fuck is the...
Where are we?
Okay, and then we're gonna...
Let's see...
Where are all these other buttons, though?
Transporter mode?
TA?
I know what these buttons does, but they look cool.
Oh, this is like radio!
Oh!
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa!
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Okay, there you go.
Sorry, I just realized, like, my thing started going...
Wait, what about the controls above me?
What are these?
Oh, cabin temperature!
There we go.
I gotta make sure we're extra nice and cozy.
And then...
There we go.
Now that seems better.
Now everybody is nice and cozy.
And then...
Where all these buttons do?
Cover?
What the fuck does this cover do?
cover do.
That's what you want to hear your pilots say.
What the fuck do all these buttons do?
Cabin temperature, cargo temperature, APU starter.
Ooh.
Oh, it's too...
Oh!
That'll be fine, right?
Whoa!
Is everything okay?
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
It's fine.
We're fine.
What do you mean we're going to crash?
Did I turn off the engine?
Oh, did I turn off?
Oh, what did I press?
Oh, I turned off the engine!
Oh,
it's fine, it's fine, it's fine.
We're still in the air.
Guys, how do I turn it back on?
I pressed so many buttons.
Guys, guys, how do I...
What did I press?
Is it the battery?
Where is it?
Where is the battery?
Oh my god.
Where is it?
Oh.
Oh my god.
Did I do it?
Did I turn it back on?
Guys, it's okay.
It's okay, guys.
Nothing bad is gonna happen.
Guys, none of the lights are on.
I don't know.
I should be alive.
But all the lights are off
Okay, I don't know why I should be alarmed
Oh God, oh God, oh God Oh, I turned it on oh, oh
Guys, we're okay.
Manchester Center, Boeing Alpha Sierra.
747 is type Boeing B748 5 miles northwest of Carlyle,
11,000.
We're okay, guys.
Guys, they lost my thing.
Guys, I think the autopilot went on automatically.
Wait, are my engines off?
Where's the engines?
Batters.
ACU January on on on on on everything's eye one one one nine
or decimal eight seven five Boeing 747 Scottish Center
Boeing Alpha Sierra seven four seven eight thousand six
hundred feet middle why did I turn off I pressed so many
buttons turn on so many buttons guys i don't know when i
turn up there are so many buttons guys oh the throttle is
down here yeah it won't let me fly anymore can
i turn the autopilot off Is this because I have autopilot
on?
They're not letting me have control of the plane!
We hate this.
Guys, caution!
We don't have control of the plane anymore!
Okay, we gotta figure out which is the engine.
We're just gliding We're just gliding I can't Where the fuck
is the engine?
APU generated?
Where the fuck is that?
They didn't teach me this at pilot school APU Where the fuck
is Oh there it is Oh wait it is on Oh Did I turn it on?
I have it on!
Are we okay?
We're sort of off course.
We're so off course.
It is!
It's on!
I turned it on!
Everything is on!
I hit the ignition?
Where the fuck is that?
There's a TV.
Guys, I don't...
I think we're off course.
We're so off course.
Mark.
Guys, our altitude is going down.
Guys, our altitude is going down!
Oh, no!
It's gonna be okay!
We're gonna be okay!
Oh, no!
I can't!
It's not...
The autopilot won't let me pull up!
Oh!
No!
Okay, okay, we're gonna figure this out.
We're gonna save the day.
Oh, my God.
Where the fuck is the engine?
Closed.
Oh, no.
We're at 2,000 altitude, guys.
I had to close.
Open.
Is that it?
Oh, what the fuck?
Oh.
Oh Because it was guys we hit the ocean that
Guys, oh no guys, we're gonna laugh safely.
It's gonna be so safe
We're safe We're so safe guys.
We're so we're so okay.
We are so okay.
We're so we're so okay guys The plane is still intact!
The plane is still intact!
End of flight.
Guys, see?
Everything is okay.
To automatically reset the aircraft in the air?
It's like nothing bad happened.
Hello.
Passengers, welcome to Dokey Flight 69.
What you just experienced was incredible turbulence.
And it was just a very, very bad dream.
So do not worry, we are still in the air, passengers.
hope you enjoy the flight and uh we hope you continue to
take joki airlines saved
it was just really bad turbulence chat just incredibly
terrible turbulence i should go faster all i'm saying is the
plane was not on fire we're we got saved okay we're gonna
reach it we last three all right we gotta go up though and
then go all the way up okay we gotta go up well i hit like
what 30k look we have engines now i don't know what i turned
off agent thank you for the super chat thank you thank it
we're gonna have to relive this bro no we're fine dokey
airlines knows exactly what she's doing no refunds you
already paid there's no refunds on this flight chat We're
just going to go slowly up.
Slowly higher.
How do I change the...
Okay, we're going to go slowly higher, guys.
This plane will not crash when I'm on the pilot seat.
I got to figure out how to land this plane, though.
I skipped that in my...
My teachers felt like I was doing so well.
That...
Oh, wait, wait.
Can I do a barrel roll right now?
I should be able to, right?
How far I'm up.
Okay, at 10,000 altitude, I'm going to try to do the barrel
roll.
It should be fine, right?
At 10,000.
altitude?
Guys, it should be fine.
Nice.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thanks for the nightmare.
We're gonna be okay.
We're gonna be so healthy.
It'll be so funny.
Okay, we're gonna do it at 10.
That should be enough altitude.
That should be enough, right?
Right, guys?
That should be enough.
Oh, what does that sound?
What does that sound mean?
Okay, you ready?
Watch this.
Guys, this is a lot slower than I expected.
We're still at 11,000 altitude.
Good day to you too, ma'am.
Good day.
Oh.
We got pull up.
We got
1,000.
Pull up.
Pull up!
We're okay!
Oh my god!
I told you we're- I told you ten- oh my- I am a fucking
prodigy.
Uh, passengers, make sure to fasten your seat belts.
We are going- we- we're in a really, really, really bad
turbulence there.
It is okay.
We hope you enjoy your flight and Doki Airlines.
Thank you.
Guys, oh my god.
That turbulence was fucking crazy, though.
Am I going up?
I'm going up, right?
Yeah.
That turbulence was insane.
Air traffic.
You fly in Microsoft Flight Sim in future.
We do crew flights.
I love that, Joe.
Join.
Don't.
I'll be adhering to Vatsim real time.
and such thing it was super chat thank you thank you there's
multiplayer in this game what the fuck's the multiplayer
dude the much the fucking multiplayer co-capped oh my god
does that mean like i could accidentally hit another plane
that's so scary oh my god that's so scary
jesus christ it's like pvp but with planes we're not
stalling we should be fine why is my engine going down is my
engine okay should i be worried that my engine is going down
should i be worried about that also like if i have a
co-pilot i feel like my co-pilot will stop me from will stop
me from doing the right thing is the seven four seven seven
new castle approach going alpha seara seven eleven thousand
eight hundred feet guys did you see that sick barrel roll
that i did though that's so funny i still have 341 that's it
i'm landing my plane closer there has to be an airport
closer mr remember this as a day the collective lifespan of
all dragoons was reduced by 10 years thank you for those
things i thank you goodbye manchester center boeing alpha
sierra 747 13.
picked somewhere so far away it's so far i'm only like i
only like did a hundred fucking meters agent thank you for
the super chat thank you thank you as an aircraft mechanic
you're not the worst pilot that is like a bit concerning not
gonna lie but thank you for the super chat thank you thank
you that's like just a little bit concerning that i'm not
the worst one all right let me like make sure you guys don't
fasten your seat belts too Uh, where was the seatbelt thing?
Here you go.
Seatbelt.
Oh, seatbelt's already off.
Good.
That's good to know.
I already thought about your safety.
Oh, these buttons do.
So, what do these buttons do?
Oh, no.
Go back up.
I need a throttle.
Okay.
I'm gonna keep going.
Just a little.
Wait, 15k altitude.
That's not...
Oh, but...
But what if, okay, I'm going to drive lower.
I think it'll be so funny.
If I drive, like, what is, like, the lowest that I can go,
like, altitude-wise?
Like, 10K?
Or 5K?
Okay.
What's the lowest?
It'll be immersive!
Above the ground.
Okay.
Does it affect my speed?
It's not like it's going to affect my speed anyway.
way i still have like 330 it's so far it's so please don't
pay for altitude sorry guys you cheapen out doki airlines
you guys you guys cheapen out on the tickets oh my god okay
we're landing our plan on fucking peter lee airfield this is
way too far all right fine fine we'll go to 100 feet.
We'll go to this airline.
We'll go to your original destination.
Oh, lower the higher altitude, the faster.
Guys, you should have said that in the first place.
Then I'll go higher.
There you go.
Request clearance to transition Charlie.
We're going to go to...
You guys need to tell me that earlier.
If I knew that earlier, incorrect high altitude.
How do I reset that?
Am I okay?
Charlie Airspace.
Don't answer that.
We're going to space.
We're going to the moon.
Hello passengers.
There has been a correction regarding our flight path.
We are now going to the moon.
Thank you.
I know we hope you enjoy your time at Tokyo Airlines.
Alright, now they'll know.
Oh, what's that sound?
I don't like it when I don't know what the sound is.
No, we missed.
No, our airport's still there.
We just need to go higher.
To the moon, we go.
So, you need an altitude adjustment.
What does that even mean?
Thank you, little super chat.
Thank you.
Black.
All right.
I wonder if I can let me go higher.
Ooh, I don't like that sound.
All right.
You're an airliner?
Enterprise.
give a super chat thank you thank you yes i'm in the
airliner but it's important because i have passengers on my
plane um those are slow flight airplanes are fast fly those
also do you ever put the landing gear up that is a really
good question we should change our pov to you know guys i'm
actually curious did i
How do I check?
Guys, how do I...
Guys, where do I check regarding, like, my POV?
Is it the camera?
How do I change my POV, chat?
Guys, how do I change the POV?
That's a very...
Is it the camera?
Okay.
External.
Alright, let's check.
No, see?
Look!
I did it!
I know what I'm doing.
Guys, I know exactly what I'm doing.
Alright, let's just look up from here.
There we go.
Whoa, the turbulence is hitting hard.
Look at that.
Whoa, guys.
Sorry about the turbulence, guys.
All right.
Nice.
We should be fine.
Whoa.
We need to go up the altitude.
We're still like, we're at 18K right now.
Okay, can I like go?
make sure our engine is higher there you go we gotta go at
least 30k right 30k is the i can still see the city though
i'm gonna make sure we don't see the city okay don't worry
i'm at full speed now all right what's the best 30k right
all right we're at 20k up we go oh my gosh
It's a party up here!
No worries.
It's fine.
It's not stalling at all.
Alright, 20k is good.
It can be higher, right?
My lunch.
Guys, I'm sorry.
We're experiencing some really, really, really bad
turbulence.
Are the engines supposed to be near red?
Yeah.
Because we want to be faster and higher.
35k is the norm okay we're gonna go up to the moon we go we
go higher i wanted to get up turkey for spooky wild ride
look we're going faster we're going higher we're at 23 000
let's go i think we can go higher i think we can go higher
We're going even higher.
Full speed engine.
We have so much fuel.
We're still only at 50% fuel.
24.
Oh my god, we're going to be so high up now.
30.
We're going to go to space.
Can we actually go to space?
What happens if we go to like 40?
How many altitude is space?
Many.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Correct.
Oh, my gosh.
What do you mean?
Incorrect.
High altitude.
Ooh.
Ooh, I don't like that.
Okay, here we go.
Don't worry.
I like it still.
They're still going to go up.
Okay.
We still need to go up, guys.
We're not there yet.
Space is 100.
Oh, my.
Can I reach 100?
Is that possible?
Gary, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you as someone who just recently been on a
flight for the first time and is now obsessed with planes i
love this you wish you had a pilot like me right thank you
it's only dropped down like 10 since oh my i thought you
said the higher we go the higher we go the faster we are get
i feel like i feel like we're still like super fucking slow
45 ks on max fucking cowards actual cowards oh my god we are
like 290 now it's gonna take fucking forever who told me to
fly to Belgium who the fuck told me to do that
oh my god i'm just gonna go higher still we're gonna go up
higher higher We're going to go all the way to 30, and then
we go all the way to 30, and then we go back in the cockpit.
How am I not moving?
Is it because, like, oh, I...
Whoa.
So all the luggage is on the tail now?
Uh, alright, there we go.
There we go.
That should be good.
We should be good now, right?
Now that we're at 30, yeah, alright, we can change the
camera.
now all right camera cockpit there you go nice we did it
yeah we fucking did it look at us go we're so good at this
whole thing thing good thing that passengers didn't uh
didn't put on their seat belts all right that's it i'm
fucking all right that's taking it how
Can I turn it on?
Why is whenever I turn on autopilot, it just goes to the
right?
Why did I do that?
Every time.
Every time I turn on autopilot, it flies to the right.
No, it's not.
I'm fucking putting it on.
I don't like that.
We have to...
We have to go here.
I have to program the autopilot.
then what's the point of having autopilot if I have the
program in myself what's the point of having AI if I still
have to do my own job like oh hey is that the landing gear
oh okay we figured it out we figured it out we know where
the landing gear is all right guys there is a chance that
this pilot might just land in the ocean
There is there is a slight possibility
There is a very judging by how far left we have There is a
great possibility that she is going to land in the ocean
Because she does not have enough time before their meeting
on YouTube Just a little bit just a little possibility
just a little possibility we're not sure yet we're not we're
not sure yet but like judging by how fast we're going which
is not as fast as i would have liked uh
we'll be fine i'll have my landing gear on mr youtube is
waiting right now and like i'm gonna put my lat don't worry
where's the landing gear i saw it here there you Landing
gear is on.
Selected altitude.
Can I get it higher?
Okay.
Oh, is this my autopilot?
Oh my god, it's 50,000 feet.
That's my selected altitude.
What is this?
Vertical speed.
Okay, and then...
Are we in the water now?
Is that the water?
this has to be the water's blue oh this is not the water
let's see okay so this is speed uh caution okay I'm gonna
turn off the caution so I don't see it um if anything bad's
going on I won't be able to know if anything's bad going on
which would be great for me and then Oh, yeah, we're
definitely...
Guys, there is a possibility that I'm gonna land right here.
There is a huge possibility.
But before that...
Okay, pilot.
Before that, I gotta make sure...
I'm gonna make sure to warn you guys first.
Alright, give me a sec.
Uh...
Don't worry.
Give me a sec, guys.
I need to make sure that we are...
We know that we are landing.
Where is the...
Where is the landing script here?
Where the fuck is the landing script?
Safety briefing.
Captain's announcement.
I don't need safety.
We're so safe already.
We're so safe.
Why do I need safe?
Okay.
Flight...
Flight landing pilot script.
All right.
Sample radio calls.
Departing.
I don't need to know departing.
I need to know, like, landing.
Guys, we might be slowly going down, but it'll be okay.
It'll be okay.
Guys, it'll be okay.
We're slightly going down.
Okay, here we go.
All right, I'm ready.
I'm ready, chat.
Look, see, everything's fine.
everything's fine why are you guys freaking out our landing
gear is on uh let me grab the camera okay external is my
landing gear on there we go it is okay it is all right all
right chat
okay we're fine why are you all so scared I don't understand
why are you guys all so scared we're so all right we're so
fine all right hello this is your captain speaking dokey
bird
I'm going to please ignore that to the passengers who have
heard that please ignore that we are doing okay right now we
are already starting our descent procedure into the ocean we
expect to land in 10 minutes if you want to adjust your
watch it is now 10 p.m.
in the ocean now the Better in the ocean is quite nice.
But it's like maybe like three degrees in the ocean.
So make sure you have your life jacket on.
We wish you a pleasant stay in the ocean.
And we hope to see you again very soon.
On behalf of our crew, thank you for choosing Tokyo Airlines
as your airline today.
Thank you.
All right, guys.
I think that went well.
Chat, I think that went really well.
Let's go down.
Alright.
Yay.
Oh, we are going down, down.
Don't worry.
We can make this a safe.
Oh, my God.
It is.
To retract.
No, no.
We're going to have the landing gear of the sea ocean.
We got to land on the ocean.
Oh, it's vibrating, guys.
That'll be fine.
2,000 altitude.
We're fine.
Look, see?
Alright, we're gonna make it.
I think I should be in the cockpit when I land in the ocean.
I won't know what that's like.
Alright.
Look, see?
Everything's fine.
I don't know why everybody's so worried.
Alright, 1,000 altitude.
900 800 all your passengers that's good they get to have
they get to sleep 800 we're almost there
600 500 altitude and we gotta make sure whoa wait we're
going up and crap.
Look, see, everything's fine.
Okay, we gotta make sure we're aligning a bit better with
the ocean.
Beyond the water, does it hurt?
Okay, 100.
It's okay, guys, just a little bumpy.
The ocean is just a little bumpy, chat.
The one.
That's okay.
The ocean is just a little...
AI is correct.
Guys, it's okay.
The ocean It's just being a little bumpy.
We'll be fine.
It's like landing.
We're okay, guys.
See it?
Look.
There we go.
What the fuck does that look like?
We did it.
We forgot to mention to you that Jesus reincarnated into a
plane.
Welcome to the Dochi Airlines Jesus experience.
We did it!
We did it, guys!
Shut down Eric.
Oh my god, it's the end of the flight.
How do I shut down the aircraft?
How do I shut down?
Shut it down.
How do I turn off my plane?
The way I turn off my plane?
I guess like...
There you go.
Shut down aircraft systems.
How do I turn off my plane?
Was it when I pressed all these buttons earlier?
Flip all the buttons?
Is that it?
Okay.
There we go.
Shut it down.
Off, off,
off, off.
off off off oh i always knew the ocean was yeah jesus took
the plane we did it we should the landing gear worked chat i
fucking knew it worked what if i did it i knew i knew i was
meant to fly yeah
a time of flight for we made it in 45 minutes oh my god we
actually did it oh yeah jesus literally took the wheel we
fucking did it chat didn't they get two in one ticket to
dokey airlines and dokey cruise shady thank you for the
magenta super thank you thank you we fucking did it guys oh
my god i knew i was meant to drive the plane i fucking oh my
god Wait, is that a fighter jet?
Okay, wait, wait, wait a minute.
Wait a minute.
Is that a fighter jet right there?
Oh my god, this is the right flower.
Okay, we're not...
Wait, wait a minute.
Okay, wait.
Let me fucking get a closer one.
Okay, set as departure.
Okay, we're gonna do a quick fighter jet.
I think we...
I think, like, we've made it.
I'm gonna...
I didn't think we...
We definitely made it.
I just want to know what it's like.
I just want to know what is this like.
Okay, we're going to turn on the sun again.
Wait, I can't, I can't, I can't drive the plane.
Wait, I'm already in the air.
Oh my god.
Bro, what the fuck?
There's more buttons?
How's there more buttons than the fucking...
What are all these...
How are there more buttons?
Where are these codes?
How do I shoot the gun?
Where's the shoot part?
Whoa!
Oh my god!
Okay.
But how do I shoot the gun?
I want to shoot...
The only reason why...
Oh.
Oh, wait, is that the eject button?
Is this eject?
Oh, I can't press it.
A lot of these buttons are inoperable, I think.
Yeah.
I wonder why.
I wonder why they're all inoperable.
This is going to be fine.
Tail hook.
Right engine, right battery.
Oh!
Okay, I need a rumor not to do that.
The weapons are deactivated.
what's the point of I can't even fucking shoot the plane
that's fucking it I can't believe it I can't believe there's
no point there's no ammo on this plane I can't believe it
can't fucking believe there's no ammo there you go all right
all right guys I think cruising up here is the way I can't
even check it it was the third person looks like what does
the third person look like okay external oh my god i look so
cool but i can't shoot in this plane i can't believe i can't
shoot in this plane we can i land it at least how do i land
this how do i land this plane ocean oh my god jesus take the
wheel again jesus take the wheel jesus take the wheel jesus
it's okay everything's fine but i should like slow down
everything is okay everything is okay don't you we got me a
jet see Jesus we'll be fine take the wheel Jesus it's like a
bouncy castle okay am I okay there's like no engine now
there's the ocean there's the ocean why the fuck do I land
this play don't worry We're gonna land very safe Yay
Wherever the plane is There it is, there it is, there it is
Airspeed too low Co-pilot, you don't fucking get to decide
what I do There we go Easy
We fucking did it boys Look at that Here we go Jesus Plain
did it again!
The Jesus Plain did it again!
What can she not do?
There you go.
See, everything's fine.
Everything's fine now, guys.
Look at that.
It's beautiful scenery, too.
Very beautiful.
That's fun!
That was really fun.
Alright, I hope you guys Enjoy Doki Airlines chat.
Oh my god, I didn't realize there's just...
I'm surprised my PC was able to withstand all of that on
high settings.
Not gonna lie.
I was like really worried because everybody was like, oh,
this is gonna PC stress test.
I was like, oh, what do you mean a PC stress test?
I don't even have...
I didn't even like plug it or take it out of my new PC out
of the box yet.
Because it's so much work.
It's so much work.
But I really enjoyed it.
That was like, I can't believe there's like multiplayer for
flight simulator.
Like I can't believe.
I feel like people really hate me if I'm on the multiplayer.
Because I don't take it seriously.
I feel like I'm just gonna like, I'm just gonna accidentally
like hit another plane.
And I'm gonna yell, get yelled.
I feel like I'm just accidentally gonna hit somebody's plane
in the sky.
make my own route.
I don't even follow any route.
I just make my own route.
Also, like, if I have a co-pilot, they would definitely not
like what I do.
Anyway, guys, in 12 minutes, I have to go to the YouTube
meeting, but I hope you guys have had a fun time watching
today.
That was a really fun game.
I definitely enjoyed how immersive It wasn't pressing all
those buttons.
I still don't know, like, 80% of the buttons I pressed
today.
I still don't know.
80% whatever the fuck I pressed today.
But I enjoyed myself.
I enjoyed myself.
Anyway, guys, I hope you guys enjoyed Joki Airlines and you
would choose our airline again for another flight.
As always, everybody, say hydrated, posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stood up for me, head to bed.
you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.